you're shining in this gorgeous having
so much fun in this mew mew dress I have
to show you the bag dude okay come on
come on
nobody my mother said it looks like it's
strangling me but I beg to differ no man
it's holding you up right I agree I love
a great choker nominated tonight how
does that it's so exciting I love coming
to the SAG Awards it feels really
special to be nominated personally but
also to be nominated as an ensemble our
cast is so incredible we get to
represent so many different types of
women on the show and that's the magic
of this show it's a true ensemble show
and it's such a joy any updates for the
new season well gosh our characters are
in Las Vegas for the new season and well
here's a fun update I'm going to be
directing an episode this season so that
is very exciting I start shooting this
day that's very exciting I've talked to
other actors who have turned to the
direct insurer I know for so many people
it's a dream has it been a dream of
yours to direct
yes I've wanted to do it for a long time
but I haven't had the opportunity until
glow and it's another great thing about
working on this show and having female
showrunners having females at the top
and wanting to foster new female talent
so I had told them that was something I
wanted to do in our first season and
they're giving me the opportunity this
year it'll be the first thing I've
directed and I couldn't be more excited
so do you which episode is it it's
episode 7 out of 10 nice breaking news
I've really told no one but I'm it's
coming up so soon thank you for telling
me I appreciate you and Dave are about
to celebrate your two-year anniversary
correct yes so Valentine's Day is coming
up we're celebrating love how did you
guys meet we met at Mardi Gras in New
Orleans no way yes we did he was there
shooting a movie and
I was out there celebrating Mardi Gras
with some friends and I was with a
mutual friend of ours and she introduced
us
I love that and the streets of New
Orleans that's my favorite that's where
I came here from so I love that more
than you know New Orleans is my heart so
I'm glad that it's great we got to get
back there it would be a great place to
go prior to your wedding universe
we got to make this happen and he's a
real gentleman for letting you shine
shine he looks handsome he looks very
handsome
always
[Applause]
[Music]